you want to know what I am Pro a freak
Show I love a good freak Show like when
people start fighting in the middle of
the street or there's a car wreck you
know I'm stopping I'm gonna ask him to
pull that wreck a little closer so I
could see like hey police can you uh
fill me in on the backstory what's going
on like I love this what's going on
fellas what do we got here
[Music]
we're live what's going on how are you
what do you think uh I guess is this the
first time we've talked since deer dick
since uh since you moved into a small
woman's bedroom or something what do you
what is this where are you
I'm visiting family for a month in
Brooklyn and I've had to rent a place
it's impossible finding monthly like
like a like a three month rental very
hard to find so we use Airbnb and it's
the best I can do all right how's it
look does it look like Victorian or
something yeah it looks like um I feel
like my sister had this little princess
bed growing up so it reminds me of that
um what uh what you got today you gotta
I could see your eager for something
what do you what do you have I'm eager
for something and
let me preface this by saying I'm not a
political guy I'm not really
conservative I'm not really liberal
I'm not pro-vaccine I'm not anti-vaccine
like I'm not I'm not liberal I'm not
conservative I'm best described as
aggressive
I'm really I like I not only do I I just
don't care it's the thing but you want
to know what I am Pro a freak Show I
love a good freak Show like when people
start fighting in the middle of the
street or there's a car wreck you know
I'm stopping I'm gonna ask him to pull
that wreck a little closer so I could
see like hey police can you uh fill me
in on the backstory what's going on like
I love this hold on fellas what do we
got here
when I yeah when I flew here I I flew
here I you know and I download TV on my
YouTube app it was three episodes of
cops that's the kind of guy I am so
what's got your eye what's the freak
Show that's got your eye so basically
this Joe Rogan Kennedy thing so here's
the background Robert F Kennedy uh you
know he's he's Kennedy Jr I don't I
don't know what his acronym is he needs
a good like RFK junior rfkj is that it
um so basically this guy he I actually
saw him talk a couple times because I
like went through an obsession with the
Kennedy family but he's Robert Kennedy's
who's JFK's brother so he's JFK's nephew
he's running for president now and he's
been doing the Pod circuit he went on
all in and then he recently went on Joe
Rogan and I don't even know all the
things that he said
because I don't really care that much
but he said a lot of things that could
be
categorized as anti-vaccine so but and
here's what happened this is the cool
part
there's this famous Professor and uh
kind of famous vaccine guy who's been
tweeting all of his opinions and
everything he tweeted out that he says
Spotify has stopped even sort of trying
to stem Joe Rogan's vaccine
misinformation it's really awful and
from all the online attacks I'm
receiving after this podcast it's just
absurd and it's clear many people
believe this nonsense
now here's where it gets interesting Joe
Rogan is the type of guy who doesn't
normally respond to this type of stuff
he kind of he seems like he's got thick
skin he doesn't really get bothered by
this but the same on the same day he
replied and he goes Peter if you claim
what rfj junior said is misinformation
I'm offering you a hundred thousand
dollars to the charity of your choice if
you're willing to come onto the Pod and
debate him on my show with no time limit
from there
it it's snowballed so now it's up to 2.6
million dollars of other people so Bill
Ackman put up 150k Dave Roman Reuben
100K Patrick bate uh Patrick that David
100K I think even like uh Andrew Tate is
now offering 500. Jason callican is
coming in with a hard 10K trying to slip
that in and say I I'm with you
put me down for a put me down for a buck
yeah well here's the thing I was like
thinking about this I'm like should I
hop in on this and just like say some
number like
collecting from these people no one's
collecting yeah how could I insert this
and how can I insert myself into this
situation but now it's 2.6 million
dollars to get this guy on the show and
I'm I think he said so far that he's not
going to do it and I just thought
this is awesome I love a good freak Show
I love like I think that uh we actually
have a presidential candidate coming our
pod soon
um I don't know if you know this yet but
I've said it actually don't tell me I'd
love to be surprised
yeah I love a good team he's a guy he he
uh he started a pharmaceutical company
his name's Vivek and uh he like he dm'd
me like six or 12 months ago saying he's
gonna run for president and I like
laughed at it I didn't laugh at it I
just didn't even respond which is worse
you know what I'd love to do because uh
I think that guy's cat interesting but I
think what would be more interesting is
if we have because he's kind of let's
say a uh you know an upstart candidate
or whatever like he's like you know not
the favorite he's not the leading guy
um I would it would be great if we had
two
of the upstart candidates come on at the
same time and so we could debate them
because it's actually kind of boring
when you have one candidate come on and
uh they just kind of monologue their
piece for for a very long time like I've
seen a bunch of these guys go on
podcasts and frankly it's kind of boring
when that happens I would love to have
like the most pipsqueak debate of all
time it's like us moderating we don't
know anything about this
only like half a percent in the polls
and we're just like it's this is The
Showdown hundreds of dollars donated to
charity
what's the question gonna be like what's
your opinion on car crashes like we
don't know anything like do you like
websites ending of Breaking Bad good
or a little underwhelming
yeah like
yeah
I want to talk to her I want to see what
she's got to say about you
dude like we don't know anything but
last time what was the Asian guy who ran
last year who like said he loved math
yeah dude
did he run and say I love math I mean
that's just like I think that was like
an explosion it was like make math great
again I thought that's what it was but
he he messaged me all seasons a year
before well he messaged me before like
one of our events hustle God he's like
hey I'm gonna run for president can I
come talk and I was like I wanted you to
be VP I was like dude you're gonna make
me look stupid by some crazy guy saying
he's gonna run for president you're like
that guy on the street who like holds up
a sign you know it says like aliens are
coming I can't associate with that and
then turns out he kind of made a good
run and so this time I was like I have
to take this at least a little seriously
and so that's why we have to have Vivek
on but yeah what do we have two guys
being like uh
yeah we just asked about their workout
routines because we're going to compare
you on things that we value in other men
so you know like here's a situation a
person breaks into your house and we
just see how they react and the reason
I'm bringing this up is I'm not one of
these guys that says like oh like I
think Jason calcaneus said this he's
like
podcasts are gonna shape the next
president
the next president will be will be
decided off of podcasts or something
ridiculous like that
by the way do we have a little beef with
Jason kalkanis he's kind of sliding into
our mentions here he's coming in a
little hot I gotta say
I like Jason calcanus but uh if if he'd
like some internet beef
I would happily be the recipient of some
internet B yeah yeah
grass-fed internet meme sign me up
I like Jason too I've only hung out with
him a couple times and he's always he's
always been nice to me but he's been
nice to me in like a rude Uncle type of
way where it's like patchy on the head
he's like a compliment yeah yeah he's
like oh that podcast you have it's
really great I think it's precious yeah
you know what I mean like he's like it's
like yeah Jason said he loved my startup
but then he said he was cute at the end
yeah
um yeah so but if if for the sake of
entertainment I'm happy to I'm happy to
to call him out uh I want to do two
things so first uh on your birthday I
tweeted out um you know just a little
thing and then he he he came into I I
tweeted out a thing I was like yeah
happy birthday too and I I made up a
bunch of nicknames I was like the
vanilla gorilla the long arm of the law
you know whatever the two percent milk
himself Sam par and I was like you know
give you a little shout out like that
just freestyling and um
he he replies with the the like hmm
think face as if
because I think I was like what the hell
is this what does this mean and then
somebody they were like oh I think he
thinks you stole his shtick from all in
where he he gave them nicknames like uh
the Sultan of science the queen of
quinoa whatever right and uh is that
adjacent calcaneus trademark yeah yeah I
was like oh yeah you think you started
can I nickname like the like turning
left like is that a thing like can we
can we trademark blue
yeah ridiculous that's a little weird um
so yeah I do think he passes in the head
and thinks he's great but then uh
there's another another hilarious Jason
calacanus moment I gotta say from
Twitter so
um so I just replied and I said uh I
said all in billionaires talking about
billionaire [__] MFM millionaires
talking about millionaire [__] and uh
you know just like that's a that's a
description so people liked it and then
but someone someone said exceptions oh
you they go all in three billionaires
and their friend Jason
I was like okay that's a good bird and
then he came back and said you know a
bottom five lamest thing you could say
he goes more like one billionaire and
three centi millionaires
whatever
just roll with the punches
millionaire
that's like
if I had to insult someone with 100
million dollars I would call them
ascenti millionaire
like five eleven and a half
I do want a challenge by the way I want
to challenge the all-in uh podcast too
um to a poker game by the way I will
play
all of the all-in podcasts I'll play all
heads up and a game of poker
so I will play them heads up
I'll put up a hundred thousand dollars
and uh and if they be if if two if two
out of the four beat me
uh they get they get 100 Grand but if I
beat three or four out of the four
I get 100 from them they each they only
put up 25k each and I'll play them heads
up we'll live stream you really think
they'd win well I've seen the whole
thing and I will go in order from centi
millionaire to billionaire so I'll play
Jason first I have a quick work of Jason
and then I'll go Friedberg sacks and
then chamoth at the end because I think
they think chamoth is the best player uh
out of them so are you good I mean I I I
I know nothing about poker are you good
I'm better than them that's all they
need to know
I mean they named their pot after it I
mean they're basing their a little bit
of their their brand on that my nickname
is the nuts and if you know about poker
you know what that means so so you know
we have our own nicknames for ourselves
um all right let's get back to it I
don't know why I got on this Jason
Castle we could wrap up we could wrap up
this little part but I'm not one to say
like I'm not gonna make an absolute
statement like Jason did but I do think
that there is like we are going to see
that this th this little freak Show
that's going on right now is awesome for
RFK
for sure and I think we'll see a little
bit more of podcasting have a and here's
why I think that this is inside baseball
a lot of people don't realize this but
so the hustle now is read by let's say
three and a half to four million people
I have 250 000 followers on Twitter I
think yeah it's precious Sean you had uh
250 000 I've got 250 000 followers on
Twitter you have 350 000 the Pod let's
just say has a hundred thousand
listeners per episode the Pod
consistently out punches in terms of
Engagement all of those things I would
say would you agree with that in terms
of like uh people who actually like
trust and um will take action on things
uh yes
yeah 100 so I do think that for people
who don't realize or who aren't in the
game they don't realize that podcasts I
have significantly more influence over
people than I think any other medium
that I've used uh or that I have access
to I don't I don't have a big YouTube I
think YouTube would do the same but um
but yeah podcasts definitely do I I
agree with you I think podcasts are a
bit of a little bit of a sleeper still
which is you know depending on on who
you are but I I think people are are
shocked at how effective podcasts are at
swaying opinion
um I want to point out a couple other
things so some people are saying
oh Joe Rogan you're just doing this
self-serving thing you're just trying to
have this this freak show this debate to
like pump your ratings
I would say not true at all
um look at somebody's actions not their
words Joe turned down having Trump on
his podcast he turned down having uh
other presidential candidates on his
podcast that he thought would just kind
of be promotional or not a good
conversation or bring unwanted attention
uh to the Pod like saying no to Trump is
saying no to ratings especially in the
last election when he was uh or when he
was kind of on the rise and um he just
said you know I'd rather not I'd rather
not do that I'm not sure I'm the right
person to moderate that debate and
um you know I don't think that they
would be truthful I think they would
talk Talking Points you know if I had
Hillary or Biden on
um so I'm not sure that that would be a
good thing so I think you can't really
say that Joe's just doing this for
Ratings I think Joe actually I think Joe
actually thinks RFK I think he actually
sides with RFK and says all right if
you're gonna say this guy's full of [__]
come explain why and let him let him
argue with you and let's see where where
it lands uh that's the first thing
the second thing is have you seen this
guy this the scientist I saw what he
looks like he looks like I would think a
sign like I mean he just looks like a a
nerd right like an older yeah he looks
like a guy like cosplaying Neil deGrasse
Tyson so he um so check out this clip do
you take care of your immune system in
other ways do you take probiotics are
you cautious about your diet I'm not as
cautious about my diet as I should be
I'm a junk food-aholic that seems
ridiculous for someone who works with
health yeah yeah
sometimes man I just don't get it right
so you live in large we call it like
that mouth pleasure so much you're
willing to sacrifice a little bit I am
yeah you know I you know I I can I have
to concede that's the case do you take
vitamins I don't take vitamins really
yeah wow what about essential fatty
acids which are great for your brain
fish oil all these different things that
are fantastic I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna argue with you you got it you got
it
listen but it would you would have a
much better argument you're making my
wife stay here if you're taking care of
yourself a hundred percent instead of
but you still need to but you still need
your vaccines I'm sure you do but
vaccines aren't going to prevent cancer
no that's true we got to get you healthy
buddy yeah can't be pushing only
chemicals and injectable forms to
facilitate health fair enough yeah not
chemicals they're vaccines oh I'm sorry
what's in them what it's not I mean it's
some sort of chemical no no other
antigens right they're they're fluid
macromolecules what's the liquids uh
typically it would be saline or you know
salt water so it's him on Rogan it's the
same scientist I believe on Rogan and um
in the past Peter Peter Peter
um so he's he's talking and he's talking
about vaccines and uh
he says something about he says
something but he's very pro-vaccine so
he's like says something vaccines and
Joe's like yeah but you know like not
everybody feels good like putting
chemicals in their body he's like oh
it's not chemicals it's uh these are
antigens these are you know cells and
he's like okay well you know what I mean
like just putting something else in your
body like you know are you taking care
of the main things and he asked Peter he
goes he goes do you do you do other
things uh to be healthy because like
Peter's kind of like you know he's
circular in shape and so uh and he's
like well you know I I do I dabble in
junk food and Joe just starts pressing
him and I've never really seen Joe do
this but I think he wanted to make a
point he's like how how much are we
talking like once in a while or like
every day he's like no not every day
like he's like so how often and he's
like I don't know like every other day
he's like uh what do you what do you
have he's like potato chips or you know
candy or whatever and he's like do you
exercise and he's like you basically
this guy over like a two minute period
is like yeah I eat like [__] and I don't
exercise
um and Joe's like isn't that crazy like
shouldn't you
but you know better than that right like
you're saying people are crazy for not
taking vaccines or pushing against them
but like you are not doing the basics of
human health like you're not exercising
you're not eating in a nutritious way
like don't you see that that's probably
like yeah I should you know no one's
perfect uh and he's like he's like do
you really just love that mouth pleasure
so much that you it goes in on them a
little bit which oh which I've never
seen Joe do he's like generally like
quite like amenable like you know he's
not really doesn't really do that but I
think for him it's like a you know he
plants a flag around like you gotta he's
like it's non-negotiable like you know
he's like I know for me I travel
somewhere first thing I do is I go to
the gym it's just a non-negotiable it's
just something I do and then the other
guy goes yeah I do that too and I was
like no I don't think you do that too
like you could just tell him to look at
his face he's like yeah but it's
different maybe the way I'm doing it the
way you're doing it because look at
what's Happening Here
did whenever I uh when I go and pick
which doctors I'm gonna use uh like when
I move to a new city or something I
definitely
their Body Matters right right yeah you
don't want the bald Barber
um yeah like I I went to this one doctor
and she had this a beautiful vein up her
bicep and I was like
I'm in
I'm in Benny uh I was in
yeah dude that's hilarious I also think
that uh there's some other strange stuff
about this guy like uh his daughter has
autism and he wrote a book called like
Rachel's vaccines didn't cause Rachel's
autism or something like that which I
just thought was like a really
I don't know I can't imagine as a parent
doing that that sounds like just very
aggressive yeah um so anyways just I I
would say and it's funny to see the the
debate here because some people are like
there's on both sides there's Rogan you
know Macho bro which is basically like
yo bro Showdown let's go but you know
you and me behind the school at 3 P.M
they want to see a fight happen and they
really just want to see him like get
punked uh is kind of like one energy and
then the other energy is like
this is uh stupid this is not what
scientists like trying to bully a
scientist into debating when that's not
his skill like this other guy is a he's
a politician he's going to have talking
points written for him all the stuff
well he's not a politician he's not a PO
he's a wannabe politicians trying to be
currently
um but but they're basically like this
one guy's like you know uh
this is what he's doing he's going
around talking about the stuff he's been
doing that he's been giving talks on
this stuff for a long time and this
guy's you know trying to just be a
scientist he didn't sign up to be uh
like kind of a debater of this stuff
um so that's like the other point of
view and there's sort of like anti-bro
in that way of like you can't like uh
stop trying to make this a fight that's
like anti-science to do that
this one guy who I really like his name
is ishan Wong he used to be he's like
from the the uh from the tech world and
he um
he worked at Facebook early on he was
the CEO of Reddit oh his he has a new
company where he's trying to plant trees
yeah exactly uh he's trying to change
like that it changed climate by by
planting trees uh I just want to read
you what he said I thought he had uh I
thought he had a good point so he goes
every science attack person who's
currently on the bandwagon calling for
the vaccine doctor to go on Rogue in a
debate should be ashamed of themselves
um if you care about the truth or
science like a kind of a podcast debate
is probably the worst thing to advocate
for usually that argument goes something
like this if you're the vax doc and
you're so sure you're right you should
be willing to go on and defend it
otherwise you lose credibility that
sounds like a good statement but he's
like uh it's an example of what Plato
the philosopher would call uh rhetoric's
oral spell in simple terms what he's
explaining is like there's a difference
between what is actually the truth and
what can be said in a very persuasive
way and right you should want a medium
where it's all about who could be most
persuasive you should want to if you
want to debate to the truth you should
do it in a way where persu your charisma
your persuasiveness your loudness uh
you're on the spot thinking is
de-prioritized compared to just like
making your most logical argument and
then letting somebody take time and
refute it it's basically like I call it
the Malcolm Gladwell effect you know
like he he writes so well and even
though it's theories I'm like oh it must
be true yeah exactly exactly you when
you hear somebody who's so eloquent
you can you can conflate how nice it
sounds and how persuasive it sounds for
how true the actual argument is and vice
versa somebody could be so dry and
boring that even though they're saying
something that's really uh on point the
message is not received by the by the
market so he basically says uh he's like
you know if you really wanted to do this
this is what you would do uh so just to
finish the Play-Doh thing it's basically
um
uh oratory so just going and verbally
you know giving like a speech or a
presentation
um is
the medium where you're most likely to
have people fall under a great orator
spells and he's like people are more
like sheep than you than you want to
think and a great order can get people
to do crazy things if you've ever seen
Hitler give a speech or uh you know
Mussolini give a speech you could see
how a great order from and you've seen
it in the good direction in the bad
Direction how great order can move
people to do something and believe
something that may not they may not have
actually believed otherwise uh so
anyways his point was like if you really
want to do this they should do it
through long-form boring writing one
person should write down their argument
with uh sources cited give the other
person time to respond to each line each
paragraph of that argument and then
you'll have basically both sides of the
argument written out uh nobody wants to
do this because this is boring and um if
you actually wanted the truth though
that would be the way and I thought that
that was really good and it reminded me
of something that was in companies that
I had also seen from
from uh you Sean's blog which was he was
like yeah and companies the same thing
happens
um the person in a meeting who is
tall charismatic uh willing to put their
opinions forward basically they are 100
confident in their opinion yeah exactly
sound familiar
no I'm not holding up a mirror right now
um but basically that person is going to
like disproportionately sway what
actually happens and uh and actually
there's another method so he basically
it's called the Delphi method and the
Delphi method was basically this method
where
um you bring up a topic uh everybody
sort of presents everybody gets the same
set of facts then you write down your
initial thoughts and statements
and then they're circulated everybody
reads everybody's initial thoughts and
statements anonymously you don't know
who said this so you can't just oh the
CEOs thinks this okay I guess it's right
uh you just judge it by the merits of
the argument anonymously everybody reads
it and then you can go revise your
statement based on new information that
you've got and you update it and you
pass it around again until you get to
you know a sort of like
you know what what people believe is the
strongest strongest meritocratic um
argument after several rounds how do you
spell that it's called the what Delphi
d-e-l-p-h-i and there's a couple
benefits of this first Anonymous so it's
not just like the the the highest
ranking official gets their way second
is it's time delay so you don't reward
like for a great decision you don't need
to think of the answer like right on the
spot like if it takes you five minutes
to think of something five minutes is
nothing but in a meeting
five minutes is everything you can't
just sit there quietly thinking and
formulating an idea for for 15 minutes
or an hour uh the meeting's over by then
and so the argument has moved on by then
so this time delay and anonymity is
really important and I love this and um
I'll tell you I shared this with uh with
the CEO at twitch and I was like I think
we should do this he was like dude I
love this this actually would solve one
of our biggest problems I think we have
in our meetings which is
people think that my opinion is the
answer is shouldn't be I'm actually
usually the least informed on the topic
because I'm the furthest away from the
data
um and secondly like we reward the
loudest the loudest mouth and not maybe
the most thoughtful person who who could
have an answer and it's really hard in a
normal meeting setting to get that
person to speak
um then I'll give you one more data
point Josh Elman who's a an awesome dude
friend of the Pod he's a he's a VC plus
like now he works at Apple but he was
basically like the growth guy at Twitter
the growth guy at LinkedIn the growth
guy at Facebook like he like LED growth
at like three or four of the Robin Hood
Robin Hood he invested in Discord he led
growth at like four of the biggest
consumer hits there ever been he for fun
the other you know while he's kind of
like you know just kind of goofing off
now he for fun built this slack app that
does the same thing he's like yo slack
is kind of rewards the same thing like
whoever's online the most gets to like
say the thing in slack
um and he he created this app that was
like a time delay so you anybody could
prompt a question
and then everybody has a certain amount
of time like in the question it'll say
you have you know we'll read the answers
in four hours
so anybody could write their answer
within the four hour period what's it
called oh thinking time is the name of
it
um so just Google Josh Elman thinking
time it's a slack app and thinking
time.org is the URL and basically it
just gave you time and then you could
say all right here's what I think I
think X and then it tells you all the
answers will be released together in 30
minutes and then in 30 minutes it posts
everybody's answers at the same time to
prevent group think and I just love this
because I think these little like
nuances actually can really change the
way any group of people interact
um because I know I'm guilty of it all
the time I'm I'm loud I'm persuasive
but that doesn't mean I'm smart it
doesn't mean I'm right and uh I like
actively look for methods or tools to
counteract that this is um a awesome I'm
going to use these things I like that b
in real time I just want to call out
what just happened this is called a good
partnership where I bring kind of [__]
and Sean just kind of polishes that [__]
and we somehow get something amazing
this is this is this is called chemistry
my friend this is this is how it's done
that was that was beautiful I didn't
know you knew all that stuff and you
tied it around perfectly I'm actually
was asking those questions and I'm
writing notes I'm actually going to go
use this thing thank you yeah and the
Delphi method that's awesome um I've got
a few more things but you want to go to
one I'm gonna do a quick one first uh I
got a simple business opportunity for
people
so I don't know if you know this dude
but uh so Google analytics which is the
most popular Analytics tool on the
planet
is is changed basically shutting down
they're not saying it's shutting down
they're like it's changing for the worse
like I would love to see actually I want
to film a commercial on behalf of all
marketers out there of the Google fake
Google have fake Google analytics
commercial where it's like but what if
we made it worse in every way what if we
rethought it and removed all the key
functionality and replaced it it's
impossible to you with vague analytics
wouldn't that be better than precise
analytics it's like people wondering why
I think the reason why is because of all
the Privacy stuff the cookie stuff so
basically the same thing that happened
to Facebook
where Apple changed their rules the iOS
14 rules and all of a sudden Facebook ad
performance went down and it was like yo
genius is over there why why is why is
performance down and why don't you have
attribution like why don't you know if I
spent a thousand dollars on this ad did
I make 900 1200 what did I make why
can't you just tell me that uh you know
I put your pixel on my website you know
your Facebook you're the biggest
Geniuses in the world it's impossible
and the reason why is because now
legally they're not allowed to like use
this type of tracking that they used
before where it's not a technical
problem it's a regulation problem
meaning
the site that serves the ads can't also
track the users on third-party websites
and this is why portfolio company triple
whale exploded on one of my investments
exploded in popularity and is now like
you know on track to be this huge winner
because let's say you owned an
e-commerce store and you were using
Facebook and you're spending like we
spent hundreds of thousands on Facebook
ads every month
um we we have to know is you know how
are Facebook ads are performing and when
Facebook's ability to track that got cut
off due to regulation
people were like what's another solution
and triple it was like hey we have this
thing called triple pixel we can tell
you more accurately than Facebook how
your ads are doing and so everybody
signed up triple takes off does amazing
and so I think the same thing happened
to Google where Google had to because of
the Privacy reasons be like all right
you know what we you know there's been a
ball yeah because of the ads business we
gotta just
you know lick a finger and and guess you
know roughly you got about this much uh
traffic conversion et cetera and so
um not great so they're upgrading this
thing called ga4 it's called Uh Google
analytics lackadaisical that's like the
new update yeah
that's the update after six beers and it
needs a nap
um yeah and every marketer I know hates
this thing and also nobody knows how to
migrate from Google analytics to ga4
it's like a there's like every time you
log into Google analytics there's
literally like a ticking countdown like
it's you know season four of 24. it's
like dude
your analytics are about to explode you
need to go learn this new tool that by
the way sucks and you need to migrate
everything over because in 14 days
there's no more Google analytics for you
and um so me and a bunch of other people
are like how do you do this and we try
to migrate over didn't we're like this
is this working I don't know if this is
working out of the box
and I think right now there's a very
simple business opportunity for somebody
to go be the ga4 export expert put out a
ton of free content and be like I will
handle your migration for you and you
just cold email every business owner
that you can think of it maybe in the
e-commerce space that's where I would
start but if not e-commerce SAS
businesses whatever and be like hey
do you want help migrating over to ga4
I'll do the whole thing for you it's
done for you turn key just pay me uh you
know fifteen hundred dollars and uh and
I'll do it I think you could I think
somebody can make a million dollars in
the next six months just migrating
people over to ga4 and auditing their
ga4 to be like hey is it set up
correctly
um just as a one-person service business
or a two-person service business I agree
I need it I need it we've been trying to
like figure this out I don't even know
how to set up reports I was out of the
game for about a year and a half and
then I came back and everything done
changed I don't know how to do it dude
everyone else has changed pronouns and
Google analytics what the hell just
happened
yeah two years ago it doesn't work the
same way anymore there's no office dude
Everything Has Changed another thing
that's changed is newsletters like
people are asking me like what do we do
for this newsletter and I'm like dude I
don't know it's been two years and in
that amount of time Everything Has
Changed like when we started the hustle
it was us morning Brewing the skim and I
always I don't like saying it this way
because it sounds like it's a bigger
deal than it is because it's not but we
kind of like pioneered this very small
industry and now people take it
seriously and there's all these like
agencies around it and they tell me what
they're doing and I'm like I don't I
don't get any of that I don't understand
how any of this works it just things
have changed very quickly yeah yeah
um I was gonna say something but I
decided to to
um
to take the high road on on something I
was going to call someone out on Twitter
but I just decided not to do it I think
you'll know who it is but uh yeah I'll
avoid it
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
um okay I got another thing for you what
how would you like to hear about a
business deal that involves
one of the goats
uh that involves I like goats billions
of dollars that involves
a messy divorce let me tell you the
story about Michael Jordan selling uh
his team right now the Charlotte Hornets
that was related to a divorce in a
roundabout way so the story actually so
so a lot of people are looking at the
story right now and they're like Michael
Jordan bought this team for I think 275
million dollars and it's about to sell
for two billion the the whole thing did
he sell the whole thing I don't think
anybody no I don't think any of the NBA
owners own 100 but I think he's the
majority owner so he um the valuation of
the team at the time was 275 million
and he bought it and now it's gonna sell
for two billion dollars MJ strikes again
the go the goat strikes again the guy's
gonna make you know more money doing
this than he ever made playing and more
money on this probably than he made
through his Nike deal as well so you
know found a new found a new way to like
you know double his wealth
but what's interesting is actually who
owned the Hornets before MJ did uh so I
don't know if you know uh do you know
the story do you know who the owner was
this guy Bob Johnson does that sound
familiar
well do you know the one that was the
richest black man in America at a given
time well okay we're narrowing it down
no but maybe he's the guy who started so
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I listened
to his uh his wife was uh his wife was
like also the the head honcho I think
right him and his wife kind of right
maybe I'm not sure about that so he
starts
um BT with like uh he has fifteen
thousand dollars of his own money he
puts that in he gets 500 000 from a guy
named John Malone
and he's like look there's no cable
network there's no Channel That's caters
towards black Americans and he's like
you know we can do this we can build
this up and so they had music obviously
so it's basically like the black MTV so
they had music they had award shows
culture whatever
BT's a winner and BT wins he sells BT to
Viacom for three billion dollars which
is just an incredible outcome right so
he did he own the whole thing yeah they
were the uh I don't know what John
Malone got I don't know if it was a loan
or Equity but like yeah he owned the
majority of it so after everything is
all after everything settles Bob Johnson
is reportedly worth you know about a
billion and a half dollars one point
three one to 1.5 billion dollars and he
diversifies he puts a bunch of money
into uh real estate he owns hotels so he
owns hotel chains he owns um uh you know
a bunch of different like assets
basically
but they're all kind of like cash cash
heavy assets so building hotels that was
a lot
um he had like I think a casino type
thing or like some some gambling thing
or whatever he needed money for that
um so he's put out a lot of cash then he
gets divorced he gets divorced and his
wife gets 400 million out of the 1.3
billion awarded to her in the judgment
so that judge made a you know gave her a
very nice uh settlement or very nice uh
ruling
guess who she marries a few months later
the judge yes
I don't know if it's a few months later
I shouldn't say that Mary's the judge
which is it's just incredible wow that's
an incredible I honestly wasn't going to
tell the story until I heard that I was
like oh I gotta tell this story just
because that is that's how thankful that
is amazing so so did did but didn't they
did they freak out afterwards and appeal
it or is that a thing I don't think it
was done so so he so this happens he
buys an NBA team so he buys the Bobcats
at the time
um for 300 million dollars and um I
think they were like the expansion
franchise basically and so but they're
burning money so he's losing 20 to 25
million dollars a year he loses another
200 so he buys it for 300 then he loses
200 million operating the thing and just
operating expenses which is crazy
because there's this famous phrase when
it comes to NBA teams that nobody's ever
lost money running an NBA team and all
the owners claim they're losing money
but it's really just like a negotiation
thing against the players they don't
want anybody to know how much money
they're actually making or they'll run
it at like a slight loss but the
franchise values appreciate getting like
crazy so they're like oh poor us how
could we ever afford to pay for our
Stadium it's like dude you bought this
for 300 million it's now worth three
billion like I think you can uh I think
you can afford it
um so he's losing money
he's got all his money tied up in
Investments he's got a ton of debt he's
using a ton of debt to build this thing
he's like all right look I need to turn
this team around he hires Michael Jordan
so he's like Mike come come work for the
Bobcats you're from Charlotte and um you
know come work for the local team you
you run the team so he's Michael's
running the team
but Bob is getting stretch for cash and
basically he's got too much debt and his
shit's all about to come due and so he's
about to lose his entire Empire because
he can't come up with enough money to
pay off his his uh his note and they're
about to take all the collateral so he's
about to lose all his hotels and his his
team
do you think that in those situations
which has happened a lot they go to the
ex-wife and they're like listen
hey
uh do you remember that time that I
tried to make sure you got nothing but
you still got something can we talk you
know what I mean like I wonder if
there's any I wonder if I've never
really this is where we had our first
date uh you know why I brought you here
I just wanted to see if you had any of
those feelings left for me because uh
I'm about to lose it all so he's about
to lose it all
and he's like okay I need to like sell
the team or something but the team is
losing money and they're the worst team
they're the sariest team so he wants to
sell it for like you know 350 million or
something like that
can't find a buyer MJ comes to him and
says all right I'll buy it
um
I'm gonna buy I'm gonna buy it for I'll
put down 25 million in cash
just 25 million and I wanted out of 275
million dollar valuation so he gets like
a 25 30 discount on the team because
Bob's under pressure and has no other
choice basically he's like but here's
what I'll do I'll assume all the debts
of the team
so I'll get you off this debt which will
relieve the pressure on you so MJ buys
this team for only 25 million down and
now is going to sell this thing for 2
billion which is like a you know 100x
cash on cash return for him buying this
team which is just an incredible move
and yet another reason MJ is one of the
goods there's a shark is that story
popular I've never heard that no that's
not popular that's uh that's a that's a
MFM original an MFM classic soon to be
copycated by all of our little Fanboys
everywhere who will uh take this and
turn this into a thread a newsletter a
tick tock and an IG reel for themselves
and so you know it'll be everywhere soon
the one thing that another interesting
twist it's going to be here's what it's
going to be called it's going to be
called like Michael Jordan made money he
became a billionaire in ways that you
didn't even realize were possible and
has nothing to do with him playing and
has nothing to do with Nike here's the
story of how Michael J Michael Jordan
turned 25 million dollars yeah I wrote
your hook for you too
um there's there is more to the story
potentially so the team has sucked ever
since Jordan bought them and like
basically he actually underperformed
like the team sucked the franchise
values are down uh his franchise Valley
should be up more than it is uh he so he
didn't actually maximize the value on it
uh but it just shows when you when you
buy right it's hard to you know hard to
lose money at that point
um the other rumor is that MJ is only
selling the team because he himself owes
a bunch of money that's the other rumor
I don't know if this is true or not but
well there's always these crazy
conspiracy theories that he's like a
degenerate Gambler and like there's
always there was a I listened to a
podcast called conspiracy theories and
it was how the mob
um made him retire from the NBA or
something like that and then they there
was even theories that they killed his
life yeah that's that's the conspiracy
is that they killed his father because
he owed money and that the commissioner
told him you need to take a couple years
off because we could suspend you but
that's a bad look for you and us because
you know of this gambling problem so you
just disappear so you know that's the
that's the conspiracy theory who knows
if that's true the other version of this
is the guy who bought the team now he's
got gay pluckin he's the guy that ran
Melvin Capital which is the the hedge
fund that the redditors or the Wall
Street uh bets guys blew up in the
GameStop thing and so Gabe lost like 500
million dollars and that they were his
fund was about to go under and then he
gets bailed out by what's his name Ken
Griffin
the rumor is that Michael had given
Melvin capital A lot of money hundreds
of millions of dollars to invest on his
behalf and that they had lost it and so
um he needed cash and so that that's why
he sold it and now he sold it to that
guy he sold it to game which is pretty
crazy this is this is Juicy man this is
this is a this is a juicy grape this is
a this is a grape of a story
that is a lot of what I just said is
stitching together pieces because people
don't come out and say everything uh but
they do say pieces and then you kind of
have to assume things in between again
and he's protected Jordan's protected
pretty hard like I remember uh you
remember that rapper Chamillionaire yeah
uh he told the story he he like because
you know rappers love uh Jordan because
of well he's like a good like you know a
black a black man succeeding and they
love his brand and Chamillionaire was
like nah man Jordan's the worst one time
I tried to get an autograph from him and
Jordan goes nah I don't give autographs
or take pictures with n words and uh
like there's like the store at
Chamillionaire was like huh and he's
like at the time he was like I was
famous like not famous enough that I
thought like Jordan would bow down to me
but famous enough that like I thought
maybe I would get like oh nice to see
you Tabitha and he's like I I got
nothing I got nothing from Jordan and
he's an [__] and I and and I don't
remember how he explained it but it
basically I was like oh Jordan not a
nice guy not not nice at all I would
have thought that it was like a story of
like everyone knows that he's a jerk on
the court but I would have thought like
oh maybe that just like ends once you
retire but it sounds like maybe that's
not the case yeah I don't know why that
would end when he retires
um okay yeah so that's the uh that's the
Jordan story where do you want to go
next
all right I have got one interesting
thing so
everyone wants to say Sean what's your
Ecom store tell me all about it and you
give out little nibbles and you kind of
tell people you know things are going
well
but you want to know what the problem
with Ecom and also a lot of other
businesses that we talk about the things
that are somewhat easy to start the
valuations are [__] like a a decent Ecom
business right now what do you think it
sells for five times profit yeah one
times Revenue
which is usually which is the same thing
as a five-time traffic for most of these
so
the thing is about is like a lot of
these businesses that we talk about and
what people initially start particularly
like the really crap ones like a drop
shipping or things like that or an
agency they don't really sell for a lot
of money
and so I like the research businesses
that a can last a really long time a lot
of Ecom businesses well a lot of
businesses in general don't last long
particularly ones built off of Facebook
and things like that
um or it's a struggle at least and also
B they sell for [__] one type of
business that I've brought up
consistently is trade shows and the
reason why is I've noticed a trend where
a trade show business can last many many
many decades sometimes there's many
examples of them lasting 100 plus years
and these businesses that are okay like
they're not that fast growing but
they're good man they're consistently
selling for 10 sometimes 15 times profit
which is pretty good that can be three
times Revenue whereas a media property
like the hustle if it's only okay that
will sell for
five times profit sometimes six times
profit it depends how fast it's growing
but I was reading a flash in Flames this
is like tiny tiny tiny trade publication
that I read and they're telling this
story about this guy named Tony Robinson
he started this company in 1991. he
started this company called Uki I
believe it's Uki media and SEO is
screwed
you don't want to be Tony Robinson
yeah yeah he's screwed for a bunch of
reasons but he like never gives
interviews he's like a pretty low-key
guy but it's called Uki media and events
and you could go to the website if you
click it it's like it looks old it
doesn't look special and most of the
people in the pictures look like they're
above 60 years old
um so it's like not like particularly
new looking or they're not at least
trying to like be cool
um and but here's what's interesting
so they own 17 B2B uh trade shows and
they own a couple magazines but almost
all the revenue comes from these trade
shows and their biggest one is a 24 year
old thing called the automotive testing
Exposition or Expo and it's basically
this is like a niche amongst uh niches
it's not a car show it's a trade show
and a core exhibition that has uh it's
where the people making the machines
that help you test if your car works so
if you're building a Tesla or a Ford or
whatever you're constantly testing like
your new self-driving system or your
testing like I guess uh uh different new
components in the LCD screen things like
that there's people who are building
machines to test that this is a trade
show for those people
and I was like doing more research about
this and he was saying he goes I chose
uh I chose to specialize in
transportation and avoid developing
products or what's he say uh uh whatever
actually I was going to quote something
that's not that interesting of a quote
but here's listen to the revenue
2019 they did 32 million with 30 margin
so they made 10 million uh dollars in
profit let's skip 2020 and 21 they only
did 8 million in Revenue how they still
did 8 million in Revenue during those
periods I don't know 2022 post covid
revenue of 26 million same margin of
around uh 26 so they did 6.7 million in
profit 2023 the expectation is 30 in
Revenue nine in profit and there's a
rumor that they're about to sell for
around 12 times
profit so this 30 million dollar a year
trade show business is about to sell for
somewhere between 100 and 120 million in
revenue and he's done this multiple
times so he had one for aircraft
Interiors Expo so like people building
aircraft Interiors he sold that for 10
times profit he also had a magazine
company that he sold for only four times
profit but he's done this multiple times
and there's this there's this guy in
Hampton his name is Jonathan weiner he's
done the same thing he did Money 2020 he
did
shop talk and I think he did one more he
sold each of them for around 100 to 150
million dollars and it was like 13 times
profit I'm gonna ask him to come on the
Pod but
it's just crazy that these uh trade
shows are consistently selling for 10 or
13 times profit now here's the the
opportunity if I'm one of if I'm
listening to this pod and I'm trying to
start a business what I would do
there's a whole lot of niche
Twitter handles there's the strip mall
guy there's uh the used car salesperson
guy there's the used watch guy
I don't know this for sure but I bet
it's not just you and I like a pop
culture type of person who's just like
paying attention because it's fun and
we're outside but I bet there's people
like the strip mall guy and I bet
there's dozens and dozens of other
people like that who are in these really
niche in which the actual industry
insiders follow them and they get they
get a kick out of them
it could be like the motorhome guy or it
could be the I don't know whatever it is
I think you could partner with some of
these people and build these trade shows
because the way these these particularly
this guy Tony Robinson the way that his
thing works is I think access to the
events are free but what they do is they
hire sales people and they pay their
sales people a lot you give them I think
he even says in the article it's like 80
grand a year base but up of you they can
earn 300 000 a year but what they do is
they sell spots or boots at the at the
trade show and they create a map where
you can like see it all in different
it's just like real estate different
locations could get higher prices and
it's basically like
you know it's not like a conference like
what I used to do hustlecon or Ted Talk
where you're going to like watch content
like the content's not important you
might have speakers but that's just to
attract the right type of people it's
really to do business and so this small
I bet you there's a lot of like 10 30 40
million dollar a year businesses that
sell components that sell to Toyota it's
like just your door handle I don't know
something
and they do business there and they say
all right great I got five leads that
was five leads I can probably get a few
million dollars if I can close one of
those leads so it's worth it for me to
pay fifty thousand dollars I think
someone could do some of these trade
shows with a lot of these industry
Insiders on Twitter and I think that's
an interesting opportunity and I think
it's significantly better than many of
the other opportunities including
agencies that a lot of people are
starting online
it's harder like if there's bad weather
you're screwed or if there's a pandemic
you're screwed but these things can sell
for way more money and they can actually
last for dozens and dozens and dozens of
years so that's my pitch on trade shows
and a small opportunity yeah I love it I
I think that's great
um nobody talks about trade shows more
than you in my life and uh I was stunned
when I heard about that guy who did chop
Talk Money 2020 and I think they did the
health care one I forgot what that one
was called
um
uh those are it's really really
remarkable I don't fully understand it
meaning
um what don't you understand like uh
let's kind of walk through it so
basically
um what's the draw to get the attendees
to attend how do you tell the what what
is the value prop for the attendees is
it meet others in your industry is it
see these vendors up close and personal
is it listen to these famous people
three famous people talk what is the
core draw
well I think it's all the above but
let's go through each one first one you
didn't mention is I think sometimes it's
like oh sick I could justify a free trip
to Florida like I'm gonna go hang out
with people and also oh hey Bob who is
not really our competitor but he's in
our industry he might be there so maybe
I can go and shoot the [__] with Bob and
hang out with him but I could bring like
eight of my teammates and we could
justify this trip I think that's
definitely a thing
the second way that you get the so it's
all about this is a Marketplace so you
need the attendees to be there the
second place or second way you get there
is you need like interesting speakers so
it could even be someone who's not even
related yeah but it's like oh wow this
one person like Gary vaynerchuk like
that's not really in our industry but
like whatever like I would I've always
wanted to see what he had to say like
all right cool I can get that person and
then the third one is let's just see the
latest and greatest technology and so we
can spend one day like getting to know
what's going on in our industry but I
really think a lot of times it's rooted
in I want to get out of the office and I
can justify this three thousand dollar
ticket and I can get five of my
co-workers to go and it's an easy
justification but in this one they're
giving away the passes for free is that
correct the this UK I think
uh when I went to their website they
advertised free passes so that's the
extent of my research okay and then in
money 2020 they charge people right and
so uh how do they sell those tickets how
do they how do they build the brand from
scratch is it content first uh free
content then they lead up to it or are
they just cold emailing what do you know
about how that guy Jonathan wiener or
whatever his name was uh
how they did it well so that's why uh it
helps to have some type of audience and
so what you'll notice is a lot of these
companies their trade show and media
businesses so oftentimes they'll create
a blog or magazine in order to get some
type of audience and then they'll use
that to like use their authority to sell
tickets but other times I think what you
can do is you can just cold email a
bunch of people to be honest I think
that in order to get look I start when I
the first year that I did hustlecon I
charged 300 and I was a nobody so like I
didn't have an email list I had nothing
I got the right speakers and I was able
to get 400 people to come and that was
only in six weeks time I think it's
actually significantly easier than you
think if you go into a niche to just
tell a handful of people and those
handful of people tell a handful of
people because a really successful show
in a particular in a smallish Niche you
can do a lot of damage with a thousand
or two thousand people but then you
really start making Revenue after a year
would we do off MFM let's say we could
get magically get somebody to organize
this whole thing because we don't want
to do it what could we use our
distribution for that would be awesome
well I would never want to do this
because I think this because the the
value here is low but podcasting so you
can do a podcasting one you know we have
30 friends who are big-ish name
podcasters you could do a podcasting
trade show where you have like what are
we using now Riverside Riverside would
be a booth and like
[__] I don't know like all the [__] that
we use
it's just like the podcast the business
side of podcasting is just so small but
it's like oh man it smells good Small's
good the pro the problem is is that the
contract values yeah exactly that's the
issue you need something where people
spend millions of dollars so the
podcasting was but like but would you
ever want to go you don't leave your
house so but hypothetically a person
like you would you want to go and like
shoot the [__] with some other guy who's
a little bit ahead of you and like just
hear best practice yeah yeah that's fine
maybe okay so podcasting is one what
else I don't know dude what what are you
interested in oh it's not what about why
what do you think what Niche do you
think what type of Niche do you think
would work so for example these these
guys are doing auto parts and all the
automotive industry because it's B2B and
a bunch of people are selling uh you
know high-priced things we've seen that
um money 2020 was like Hey fintech is
gonna be a thing let's just make the
number one I don't know if those are
trade shows as much as they were
conferences but like let's make the
fintech conference let's uh let's make
the e-commerce conference that's kind of
what they tried to do with those to like
ride an upstart wave
um we could probably do something either
involving investing or high net worth
people so where and your your booths are
uh different type of like a question
that you and I and our friends
constantly ask each other is like does
anyone have like a an accountant who
they trust or I am having this tax issue
what are some lawyers that I can trust I
think you could do something in that
vein I would have to narrow in on what
it what it would be I think you could do
something like that
um where like one customer for a
particular Law Firm can earn hundreds of
thousands of dollars in a lifetime of
fees or or or a net worth uh or a
financial advisor could I think you
could do something in that vein by the
way we've been to a couple of these Farm
con I think is a is exactly this so
that's for the agriculture industry we
went to that uh another one is um
back when I was doing the sushi
restaurant I remember we somehow were at
the qsr I don't even remember what it's
called is the qsr event and I just
remember that the CEO the guy who
created it his last name was hamburger
and I was like
like I forgot what's the name of that
effect where people end up living up to
their name
um like there's like some uh there's
like a whole subreddit about this uh
Reddit people Lizzy just a big juicy guy
I mean what would you I mean just just
basically this is just the idea of
um like somebody who's named John
Hamburger ends up creating the quick the
fast food trade show like you know Usain
Bolt is the fastest man on earth like
this is just it's too good to be true uh
like if you're that wolf of franchise
guy who we like on Twitter oh you
definitely this is what he should do you
could pull up you could pull off
something like this now it's really
logistically it's still like this isn't
easy this is there's some challenges but
it's simple not easy it's a problem
that's been solved tons and tons of
times like it's not like you're
inventing we're not inventing anything
new this is a s this is we're selling
T-shirts you know it's still like
revolves logistical issues but like it's
it's not you're not inventing anything
yeah yeah that's cool
um all right I think that's that's good
I'm Gonna Save My other topics for the
for the next episode did that not tickle
your fancy it does it seems like you you
know it's good when I'm slacking in the
background because I'm just like oh
here's a half-baked idea here's a
half-baked idea uh of what could happen
I think the trade show stuff is actually
pretty fascinating and I like you know I
think there's two ways to approach a
business one is like what do I love to
do and let me just follow the like
follow my curiosity follow my natural
like scratching my own itch type of
thing
and then the other is like the cold
calculating like all right let me work
backwards from businesses that sell with
high multiples and I'm just gonna go
fishing over there because I don't know
I don't know what my passion is so might
as well just go calculate the best
opportunity I've actually done both in
my life both can work you can win both
ways I think it is better to win when
you follow your passion but like
um
but I but if you're not gonna do that
this is a fun way to to reverse engineer
what business you should be in and I
don't want to say this is like an
absolute thing but it appears as though
the comp there's lots of buyers for
these businesses because the way that
like
there's a handful of publicly traded
companies as well as um
some really like uh heavy heavy heavy
backed PE companies where what they do
is they just buy like eight of them and
they put them together and they do
synergistic stuff to reduce costs and
whatever and it seems as though it's a
very very high buyer Market whereas like
Ecom for example I don't know if
agencies are like this I I don't know
they might be they may not be but some
of the things that people start they're
they seem a little bit more difficult to
sell whereas these things aren't as
difficult to sell totally that's right
um good stuff all right that was a good
episode I like that one that's the pod
[Music]
foreign